[Música]
y en directo américa estamos con más
romero sala para hablar de una de las
aristas científicas y de salud del
conflicto en ucrania y es que las armas
químicas y los fantasmas de su uso
vuelven a planear en el ambiente que son
este tipo de armas además que son las
armas biológicas más buenos días muy
buenos días angela pues empecemos por lo
más importante que es decir que ambas
armas son consideradas armas de
destrucción masiva y consecuentemente
están prohibidas por diversas
convenciones internacionales por la
extrema crueldad de su uso y también
porque éste puede llegar a ser
indiscriminado es decir que también
puede afectar a la población civil más
allá de los objetivos bélicos pero
vayamos a las definiciones oficiales de
este tipo de armas por un lado las armas
químicas se consideran todas esas
sustancias químicas tóxicas utilizadas
para crear daño en el enemigo en un
contexto bélico herir diezmar o la
muerte incluso y es importante destacar
que esa definición no sólo incluye la
sustancia tóxica en sí la sustancia
química sino también los dispositivos
que se usan para propagar por otro lado
la definición de armas biológicas de la
organización mundial de la salud
comparten muchos puntos entre ambas con
la diferencia de que estas armas
biológicas se consideran todos los
micros organismos como los virus
bacterias hongos por ejemplo que sirven
con ese mismo propósito de herir de
dañar o de incluso matar y es
interesante que la organización mundial
de la salud incluye no sólo pues el uso
contra humanos sino también contra los
animales o contra las plantas porque
pues porque en contextos vidic bélicos
cómo se afecta a la comida cómo afecta a
la agua también tiene una gran
consecuencia sobre la población no civil
y sobre el conflicto y dadas esas
consecuencias sí que han sido utilizados
en varias veces durante la historia
desde cuándo están prohibidas pues la
primera vez que se prohibieron fueron en
1925 en la convención de ginebra después
de un uso indiscriminado que se dio en
la primera guerra mundial y del horror
que generó también pues entre
precisamente la población civil y los
espectadores de esa guerra sin embargo
fueron unas provisiones con algunas
lagunas porque pues porque se prohibió
su uso en el campo de batalla pero no se
prohibió su investigación ni su
producción eso qué en un contexto donde
todavía unas tensiones internacionales
de la segunda guerra mundial o la guerra
fría hubieron varias potencias como eeuu
rusia japón que desarrollaron
importantes programas de investigación
de estas armas químicas y biológicas de
eso también pues provocó que en 1975 se
prohibiera el desarrollo de armas
bacteriológicas y en el 97 el desarrollo
de armas químicas tanto rusia como eeuu
importante recordar que ambos son
firmantes de estas convenciones hagamos
un apunte breve de historia si me
permites también en lo que respecta a
las armas biológicas y es que en
realidad se han usado desde los siglos
de los siglos porque aunque no se
tuviera clara esta relación entre
microorganismos e infecciones o
enfermedades era obvio que las que
llamaban plagas en la antigüedad eran
muy dañinas para la población y uno de
los ejemplos más citados históricos pasa
con una triste ironía en la península de
crimea que actualmente es una de las
protagonistas de este conflicto entre
rusia y ucrania donde en el siglo 14 los
mongoles lanzaron cadáveres infectados
con peste negra sobre la actual ciudad
llamada de co2 ya pues para precisamente
10 ciudad y su población durante unos
sitio bueno que armas químicas y
biológicas conocemos y qué efectos se
tienen sobre la salud ya volviendo al
presente volviendo al presente exacto
empecemos por las armas biológicas
quizás la más conocida es el ántrax que
de hecho está generada por un bacilo que
se distribuye por esporas de eso qué
significa pues que no es contagiosa como
una gripe o como el commit mismo por
ejemplo sino que infecta cuando se
ingiere o cuando se respira eso provoca
ampollas inflamación úlceras y si no se
trata se puede tratar con antibióticos
por ejemplo puede llegar a provocar la
muerte hay un triste ejemplo en rusia
por ejemplo en 1979 por el mal manejo de
ántrax en un laboratorio de desarrollo
de armas biológicas hubo muchísimos de
enfermos en la actual ciudad de
ekaterimburgo
también existe por ejemplo lo que se
llama la toxina botulínica y de hecho
hay una preocupación aunque esa
preocupación todavía no se ha hecho
realidad sobre el uso del ébola del
virus del ébola como una potencial arma
biológica por otro lado las armas
químicas pueden ser el gas chlorine o
gas mostaza fosgeno tanto fosgeno como
el gas a clarín o sobre todo lo que
provocan es asfixia mientras que el gas
mostaza
ampollas en la piel estos gases fueron
responsables de miles de muertes en la
primera guerra mundial y también no
podemos dejar de nombrar el gas sarín
que es un agente nervioso es decir que
afecta al sistema nervioso impide la
conexión entre el cerebro y los músculos
en el mismo estilo del novillo -que por
ejemplo y eso pues puede llegar a
provocar la muerte por asfixia o por
paro cardíaco lo usó el gobierno el
gobierno sirio en la guerra de siria en
2017 también en irak contra la minoría
kurda y carl la onu lo con cifras de la
onu se calcula que las armas químicas
han matado a un millón de personas en
todo el mundo muy bien y ya para la
conclusión porque tanto miedo genera en
estas armas claro me parece que es un
punto especialmente importante que
discutamos porque de hecho hemos visto
en este conflicto que estamos
presenciando ahora este terror que
desatan estas armas y el uso de estas
armas las sospechas no sobre todo porque
son armas devastadoras sobre la vida
misma hablamos de la salud de la
alimentación del acceso al agua que son
derechos básicos humanos de la población
civil aún en un conflicto armado
entonces es por esto también que generan
ese miedo porque atacan cosas muy
para la vida también por ejemplo lo
hemos visto con estas denuncias de
laboratorios de patógenos en ucrania que
ahora podemos analizar con más
profundidad también de las bombas foso
horas fósforo perdón que son armas de
incendiarias que de hecho no son
químicas pero que también han
contribuido a desarrollar este miedo
este terror porque al final pues este
tipo de ataques sobre cosas tan básicas
lo que generan también son ataques sobre
la psicología de las personas sobre los
ánimos de las personas que en un
contexto bélico ya están suficientemente
afectadas pues mar un agradecimiento
para usted además por esta antesala que
nos da el paso para nuestra siguiente
sección nos vamos ahora con nuestro
invitado